Recall that in any modern operating system, each process is in it's own
protection domain. And usually, a separate hardware
address space. And the operating system maintains
a page table on behalf of each of these processes. The page table
is the operating system's data structure that
holds the mapping between the virtual page
numbers and the physical pages where those
virtual pages are contained in the main memory
of the hardware. The physical memory of
course is contiguous starting from zero to whatever
is the maximum limit of the hardware
capabilities are. But the virtual address pace of
a given processor course is not contiguous
in physical memory, but it is scattered all
over the physical memory. And that's in some sense the advantage that
you get with page based memory management. That a process notion of
which virtual address being contiguous is
not necessarily reflected in the physical
mapping of those virtual pages to the physical pages in the main memory.